that was expensive I'm inviting you in
saying it's for wine but I really mean
sex I don't know where stand
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you better know where to house
I'm gonna go make sure my vagina doesn't
smell like geez oh we have sex
painted that on purpose I'm gonna sexes
I'm gonna have sex I don't want you to
see my fuzz but I do want you to see in
general I when they smooth that makes me
sexy I don't want there's no sick
Russell's dress they taking your clothes
off slowly just in case your junk looks
really weird they named me to control my
facial expressions taking your clothes
on - so we've got the same procedure
right this is a nice shirt dorippa
touching your boob - that's why we're
asking you about condom but it's
actually just a formality I'm gonna get
my friend my name's Sam I'm gonna turn
that screw in the body but I'm not
making any promises
help me did you see my battle this is
the last person I have sex I really hope
this goes as good as I want it to this
cabin is gonna take a while to put on
I'm happy noises to validate me this
sound real overthinking my sexy voice
God me that's harder but I don't want
you to think you're hurting me so
thirsty not that McCann took part vomits
I am not almost there I am not almost
there I think about my grandma so don't
come that sounds nice
I kinda want to cuddle I can't I want to
cuddle too but if I go pee I'm gonna get
into the UTI first I thought